i had a terry crews today at zoo this
girl
she was talking about some show i did
i'm talking she's batting i'm talking
her
and then just mandingo just comes out of
nowhere it takes you a mark
oh yeah it's just black shadows
it was like i was some [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] shrimp she's all okay see you later
i was like
all right when i look over he's just
stretching her just
all right yeah oh well i'm gonna go now
i'll see you guys later that's what they
do with zoo is just like yo
i panicked that bro i gave her a hug and
i looked at him i bowed i got nervous
[Laughter]
you know what to do i literally laughed
out there [ __ ]
the zoo's wild bro damn they'll come up
to you let's see if i was in there and i
was talking to a girl like an instagram
influencer and i think this was her man
or
just you know an acquaintance something
the
it's so wild when someone's so big she's
a smaller girl no
oh then that matches but when the dude's
like just massive and they got bro
you know andre drummond used to date
that girl from icarly yeah that small
girl
i'm like which one uh jeanette mccurdy
uh
blonder yeah who dated her andre
drummond weird because she went on a
whole pr tour saying how she hates that
show she was she never did it
really stopped acting yeah pull up a
picture andre drummond
what's her name casey uh jeanette well
that's like shaquille o'neal and uh
that's someone else yeah yeah casey
anthony someone else jeanette mccarthy
yeah i can't see anything definitely
no i think he was a fan of the show and
he had a crush on her
he shot his shot online and they started
dating shortly after put it this way
she's not bodied up she's not at all but
she got a
she got are they still together no no i
think it was like a short
bro i bet she was exhausted
dude that's look at that exactly that
that always shocks me because like
she's like here we go yes some girl's
like accepting let me climb on top
get up there and she bro oh i bet she
was just
yeah hell you tell her look at that he
probably telling lead them right but
yeah what's even more alarming than that
is
uh shaquille o'neal and hoops yeah they
say shocked
yeah it's too short but they say shaq
has a little little wiener
but his ex that don't make any sense
where his wife started that wrong
sometimes
little wiener sometimes it's shag yeah
there's no way
i don't know hoops was bad that's even
damn that's funny
who's got something like she get you
know yeah icarly's tiny
carly bro she got a little like kylie
probably that's flat
no hold on she probably no no no no no
no i bad like carly i'll disrespect the
icard i currently have to get her mine
right every night
10 p.m yeah bro who's better than mine
right look at that [ __ ] i'm starting to
look at
now i'm noticing yeah 7-4
wait chin go to her shack laying down he
got her on uh
have a baby says hoop and shaq the
second one to the left
second one to the left i don't think i
have a baby this one go under underneath
uh-huh
hold on look at this dog
what the [ __ ] bro she's so small so
small
shack no but shaq's just so big that's
what i'm saying so y'all don't care
about that
bro her i feel like she can handle
whatever he's giving her yeah
icarly is like god you're right if you
go to flavor flavor hope you make it
girl shack you say what
shag he ain't got no little weight check
right there but but even this
if you're seven four like this ain't
that's not that's not
like to scale yeah he's seven four seven
two or seven four he's huge
yeah seven i think he's seven two seven
one wait i mean
still going in it going in an average
human
seven one though well what this is how
tall is this cup this probably i don't
know
but that going in like a girth bruh well
i don't know if he has girth but
even the the length this is probably six
inches
a dollar six inches a dollar that's so
six inches a dollar is bigger than that
or smaller than that
i don't think so that might be like six
and a half seven five you guess
anyway either way yeah
that's damaged
ain't nothing i don't think
the video like how's this gonna figure
out i don't get just to watch it how's
it gonna fit
i watched the porn so it got me it
turned me off
because it was so pulsed it was so i'm
like girl and she
and they didn't need so much blood it
like bends in the mid it's like
yeah think if you have a long like if
you build like a long black coat
it gets weak in the middle we get a
little yeah don't have it
you don't have the yeah it doesn't have
the [ __ ]
yeah so even but even that dick it's so
long it like
bends down like it's so heavy it looks
like a like a
like a what a tree trunk you know when
they get real heavy snow on them
that was this guy's day i was like poor
girl cause she tried to give him here
and she was
barely like pitching his mic and she's
just like go right here
but barely anything barely and for him
i'm like this can't be great
he's got a mouth keep going
go deeper
then she had to get up there and they
had to like hold on and it was like took
like five minutes for her to just like
finally and she didn't go all the way
through it i was like no this is her no
way she turned red i'm like oh that's
[ __ ] terrible
i hope those ladies get extra money for
going for the mandinga
they better they're probably they're
being paid more than he is they better
be your email's always been they better
ain't no way there was that guy the
mandingo on um
oh what was it not brazier's another one
um what are there more than one mending
groups yeah there's the the famous
mandingo there's the mandigo now but
there was one old
like og yeah they get older oh do you
like pass the torch to like the next
generation
i think it's just a porno like from if
you have just a [ __ ]
hog and you're small like
i see mike that was icy mike [ __ ] that
guy in there named mandiga and just like
oh man i don't
know it's too much yeah i would hate my
life if i had that
bro think about it you know you have a
big ass you you wouldn't no
that big yeah yeah you you scare girls
away
you that's what i'm saying you sound
like
i don't like ferraris man they're too
fast
okay okay i wouldn't i
don't think big dicks are gross am i
right be comfortable in your subaru
listen big dicks are disgusting am i
right guys
come on girl watch this podcast what is
chappelle talking about
no no i would hate it you would yeah why
yeah no
if it was that massive yeah yeah that's
not comfortable yeah that's
uncomfortable yeah cuz i was watching
ferrari [ __ ]
nah that's a dump truck yeah that's not
that's 18 wheeler that's that's the key
18 wheeler yeah you gotta have an extra
license to drive
no that girl was panicking too but yeah
you probably run so many girls away
think about a guy that's not a porn star
that just has that
he running girls away well that's why
you probably go into porn though
maybe yeah they got a guy called punish
her
huh yeah his nickname is punisher
punisher
wow what a great name
[Laughter]
yeah [ __ ]
it looks like they're gonna the
atmosphere so
like four or five guys i'm like leave
something for me dog oh you [ __ ] hurt
i'm like god yeah but
you hitting that dog you see the point
right there see the poor girl mascara
yeah
there's no way people just enjoy it oh
you hear one homie go yeah suck that
dick
but it's not his dick yeah y'all
yeah i love when a dude just like take
that [ __ ] girl take off i'll be like yo
shut up yeah god can you pipe your hand
it's already awkward in here
i love you your friends yeah your friend
jerome we don't know jerome
don't get that big ass kicked over there
man hurting this boy okay jerome
she had to sign the waiver when jerome
came i love when the dude don't have
nothing to do and then
all her holes is filled he'll just come
over there and just smack the ass
oh yeah no you don't sleep in the back
jack and all right
i gotta stay
just just foaming at the mouth to get in
there yeah
damn that's so [ __ ] funny dog oh my
god i'll win the
game i know this is stupid well i know
when like the girl's getting hit from
behind
and the dude getting hit and she just
take a break and then she's like oh [ __ ]
just keep hitting it he's like man just
try he tried to weasel the dick back in
her mouth and she's just a boy
like stop waiting for my favorite hitler
or even she takes a small break yeah
yeah and then he's like let me just get
one let me recoup
all right
hold up everybody chill everyone's gonna
get service
but you gotta give me time i'm baby
she's better but she better make a
million off that
oh no she made 700 bucks
[Laughter]
i'm trying to tell you they better give
her a [ __ ] bill no he's so funny
because some of those german bukkakes
i'm like what is it right now
yeah all right chin everyone knows cocky
right yeah yeah
oh why are you saying no i was just
shocked about it what the [ __ ]
how do you not know what's going on come
on
kick your ass back
[Applause]
explanation yeah it's just everywhere
like a bunch of people
coming on a girl yes it's just all
together
why don't they just call they just call
it that because it's a japanese term
right i think it's a giant
yeah let me look what it means you see
you know just go to the images you see
you see the girl just like ugh icing
icing icing
japanese like cinnabon active splashing
that's why oh that's cool i'll show the
name of a noodle dish
oh so it's a dish and they just stole
the name
but it's called flashing yeah actually
the boys so if you jump into a pool
that's a [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah i just want to say we're
interested in the camera
cocky jump in the water
oh because all the guys go on stand man
let's boo cocky this thing
let me splash it dog splash
people enjoy that bro it's just like
some girls i don't know if they like it
yeah i don't know we never hear from
them
they never do i need to watch these
podcasts afterwards you know
yeah i want to read this [ __ ]
well thanks for uh sometimes there's an
interview with the boy hole
girls now glory hole is where it's a
door and you have a dick yeah so
i know that sometimes just a bunch of
holes oh yeah
yeah it's just a bunch of dicks they had
a gory
glory hole in louisiana really yeah
that's it they had a glory hole in
louisiana
you don't know who your boys are like
bro hey you can get lit and you gotta
pay it's like
a hundred dollars i'm not gonna pay a
hundred dollars for no
yeah yeah i'm glad i'm not that horny
i'd have to see
that's a different
oh well of course it's gonna be girls
but i was in louisiana paddy so it was
popping that night he was like bro
hundred dollars it's like what 2015
and i was like all right and i know
about glory holes i wanted to
so bad but i have like all i had was a
50. i just feel bad for the girl
yeah you getting paid for me always a
girl you get paid though
that's what i'm saying yeah is it old i
didn't know that's what
like how do you know there's a lot of
gay glory holes yeah
that's what i assume it's like a guy
pretending to be a girl that's why i
said i
you know you have to stick your hand up
first and that's fair because i can feel
through the hand
this is
that's a different level of horniness
that is
yeah that's [ __ ] that's a lot it's
aggressive mm-hmm
yeah that's a lot it's a lot yeah it's a
different level yeah to be that yeah
i want to say regular regular sex is
funny gangbangs is not i'm uncomfortable
with gang bang i never ran
i never had another guy with me i'm not
no i'm
that's scary why i need to be i'm
spelled just learn what [ __ ] is
you're right take it back take it back
you're right it's an overload i know
right you just dropped
so this girl's not gonna allow him on
the show who are you hanging around
and be like babe you know what
i do and it's disgusting well brennan
keeps referring to us as the buzaki boys
keep saying where the splash bros
your girls are gonna let you on the show
get some current events how about that
when i get off stage with the lap
factory right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just run a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song